no verse undefined these are both data
types in JavaScript and JavaScript
undefined meaning that means a variable
has been declared but has not yet been
assigned a value such as as you can see
when I run this in the console
it shows that the variable test is
undefined I have created the variable
but I haven't said it equal to anything
but if I down here if I say that test
equals null and then I canceled out log
it you'll see that it shows null in the
console null is an assignment value it
can be assigned to a variable as a
representation of no value so while
undefined is set automatically just by
not assigning a value javascript never
sets a value to null this must be done
specifically in your program so let's
test some things about null and
undefined we can see the typeof null is
an object this is actually for legacy
reasons that it doesn't show a type of
null but if we check the type if we
check the type of undefined it makes a
little more sense you can see this at
the very bottom type of undefined is
undefined whoops let's clear that
if we try to check if null is equals
equals equals undefined you can see
false
now this equals equals equals is the
identity operator so it shows that the
identities are different in all it does
not have the same identity as undefined
but if we use the Equality operator
equals equals is the Equality operator
if I check that you can see the last one
is true so JavaScript does consider null
and undefined to be equal now if I check
the identity operator to see if null is
has the same identity as null as you
expect yes it's true it show its true
down here and if I check to see if null
is equal to null you will see again if
you just go to the bottom true let me
clear that now if I say you know the
exclamation point is means not so if I
say not null this is going to equal true
not null is true null is it's false
except if you console dot log null
it's just gonna say null however if I'm
gonna just put two exclamation points in
front of this and console that log and
you look at the bottom false so that's
why you'd want to use two exclamation
points one exclamation points changes it
to true and then two changes it to false
another thing interesting that if you
try to add one lesson all and I run that
that's a good actually equal once
so in math null is basically zero
however if we do 1 plus undefined it's a
little different and that's going to
equal in a in or not a number
so undefined that you can't add anything
to it because it's not a number well
thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes the code in this video and links
to more resources on the topic are in
the description
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good